well I give Sonny one thing in terms of
action games they know how to make a
demo like god of war three last year
uncharted two last year now infamous to
this year this demo is insanity if you
play it in from his one you know the
basic gist of the story you're a guy you
have electricity it may not have been
one of the captain planet abilities
apparently they know I'm over here but
like the force unleashed ooh what is it
about sequels and video games being
better than the originals that's not a
rule for movies generally speaking but
for video games lately I gotta say it is
force unleashed 2 was intense this was
intent on the same caliber one of the
abilities you get is called an ionic
vortex in which you throw an electric
tornado into the street and you just
watch cars and people and ass and death
get sucked up into it I'm not gonna like
probably do that for seventy eight solid
hours seventy eight solid hours of
electric awesome you know you could do I
got to give it up for the action games
this year in packs that is the most fun
I've had for the past two days
say no I'm here all right that's G for
people bastards so we just played marvel
vs capcom 3 and if you i assume if
you're a fan of Marvel vs. Capcom 3 and
this is going to be your game it's
everything that I remember marvel vs
capcom 2 being being a person that never
really got into marvel vs capcom 2
because it's always reminded me of like
if the Micro Machines guy and full
throttles did a bunch of coke in speed
and build a fighting game based off a
street fighter two turbo that would be
marvel vs capcom two just to say i just
panic i just end up hitting buttons that
that's just me though so if you're a fan
of marvel vs capcom 2 which everyone
over there is and they all seem to love
it and this is the game that they've
been waiting for then I suggest you go
play this game I'm going to play it
because my roommates going to get it so
but i'm [ __ ] and what can I say